[Musique]
je suis très sensible aux femmes bien
bien chaussé et je dirais que
autant le visage provoquées chez moi des
choses d'ordre ou intellectuelles ou
affective et cetera les choses qu'on
pourrait dire de à connotation érotique
ou
de pulsions comme ça à d'attirance sa
part généralement des pieds et partir
dans des chaussures le pied je laime
bien nerveux musclé bien irriguée est
pas blanc et mollasson sans forme c'est
à dire que j'aime beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup il faut sur deux femmes
particulièrement les chaussures en daim
[Musique]
antoine est à 25 ans c'est une
collectionneuse elle a la chance
inestimable des chaussées du 35 comme
marlène dietrich ou la duchesse de
windsor comme vous et fine devoir n'est
qu'un navet 500 perd elle elles
s'approvisionnent exclusivement aux
puces un peu de tout à commencé sa
collection à quelles périodes
oh ça fait cinq six ans peu près 5 6 ans
101 combien 180 père mais sont répartis
un peu partout alors didot dans ses
chaussures tu dois avoir des chouchoutes
les tout rouge la saison visiteurs du
soir sont un peu diabolique puis
vachement mystix pas le trouve très
belle en fait c'est des espèces de
pantoufles à la foule oui et non attends
je vais te montrer des biens en a qui
sont vraiment très payante qui mais je
trouve qu'elles sont bien quand même
comment tu l'as pas assez ça c'est genre
années 40
tu vois sont très malsaine de trouver
100 en python je crois années 40 mais tu
me dis que tu es folle de cinq ans oui
mais années 40 si tu veux bon mais ça se
comprend bon mettons de 48 à 50 8 h
voilà 48 à 50 8 et pourquoi cette
période
ben pourquoi cette période parce que ça
va avec mes vêtements
et puis ça va avec mes vêtements et puis
ça va avec la musique que j'aime surtout
et puis ça me rappelle beaucoup de trucs
tu vois pas ce que moi je suis né en
corse une et ajaccio et j'ai passé toute
mon enfance là bas j'ai retourné tribaux
je me rappelle qu'à ajaccio mais mettant
des to qui étaient jeunes ils ont fin
des années 50 avait des sabots alors
quand il y avait plein de soleil on
allait à la plage et les sabots
claquettes voit alors ça me rappelle des
trucs c'est moi je suis très remember
très nostalgique
est-ce que découverte un de ses shows
sur l'a1 y en a où je suis très
confortable ça y'a pas de problème il y
en a d'autres moi comme ça par exemple
tu vois la halle on n'est pas bien du
tout mais elles sont tellement belles
j'ai tellement peur des esclaves et cela
que je l'aimé jamais est ce que vous
regardez les chaussures des filles bah
moi je veux dire que ça m'intéresse pas
tellement et chaussures des filles je
préfère je préfère mes chaussures
d'abord et en plus je crois que je
préfère vraiment draguer quand même une
paire de baskets à une paire d'escarpins
c'est plus dans ma lecture c'est
beaucoup plus pour moi je à se marier
vous aimez les chaussures amiens même
pas vraiment et soucieuse presque une
obsession spécialement pour les
chaussures qui sont plates
ah bon oui j'ai une passion pour les
chaussures plates
dans la mesure où ça a un côté androgyne
ce qui me plaît beaucoup en france comme
ça on ne sait pas vraiment si une femme
ouanna et surtout parce que je me fais
moi même mes propres costumes et surtout
des costumes d'hommes soit l'époque
henri iii louis xiii et louis kahn est
ce que c'est une question de confort ça
a coûté un petit peu particulier au
niveau du confort en ce sens que j'ai
toujours peur dans la rue quelque chose
m'arrive
et puis m'arrive toujours quelque chose
alors le fait d'avoir des chaussures
plates ça permet de courir aller bien
plus vite
est-ce qu'il ya certains de ces
instruments délicieux qui vous tiennent
particulièrement à coeur
ce sont les petites chaussures avec un
petit neveu et vernis j'ai une passion
pour le vernet sais pas pourquoi
peut-être parce que ça brille et surtout
c'est un côté pratique il suffit de
passer les poules et puis pensez vous
trouvez que c'est érotique des
chaussures alors absolument pas je ne
trouve aucun érotisme dans les
chaussures absolument pas la seule chose
qui est érotique pour moi j'ai petite
culotte quand la taille haute et qui
sont en file décosse en plus des causes
comme comme bahnou n'ont absolument pas
mais basse et de l'intérieur ce qui
permet d'avoir une couture c'est du 100%
coton
ah bon voilà et qu'est ce que je vois en
parle sur vos soro cheville envoyer une
petite croix parce que voilà
bon j'ai absolument pas cette religion
mais j'ai une passion pour les
bondieuseries parce que quand même c'est
quand même une véritable cirque que
c'est comme les reliques
voilà les petites relie qu'est ce que
c'est que ça alors faut c'est du sang et
vie des petits morceaux de peau du sang
oui du sol qui goutte de sang et puis
deux petits morceaux
parce que tout ça très beau c'est facile
un côté un petit peu bizarre et j'aime
bien ça y est j'ai apprécié ça me porte
bonheur comme ça en met une idée vous
aimez beaucoup aussi les cercueils et
les vampires à vous nous enfermez les
vampires j'y crois à l'horizon des
chaussures plates
[Musique]